hi everyone I'm Milano which are Lana
Zod welcome to my channel this is my 30k
Q&A my third Q&A for hitting at 30,000
subscribers thank you all so much dr.
Ruth will be like us what's your game of
the year so far
wasteland 2 Wolfenstein the new order
and South Park the stick of truth so far
JK Taylor 95 lost who is your idol
besides your parents I kind of want to
say my grandparents but I don't think I
really idolize anyone there are people
that I look up to though and two names
come to mind when you ask this question
for people I look up to but it feels
weird saying it because I also kind of
consider them friends so if they're
watching this super awkward
those people are max Scoville and Jim
sterling cool-ass what's one gaming
franchise that you'd love to see
revitalized people who follow me on all
of the social medias probably already
know this one but it's definitely banjo
I loved banjo tooie likes banjo kazooie
but not as much so I would love banjo 3
not nuts and bolts banjo 3d budget for a
banjo 5e give me all of the banjos not
like literal banjos you know what I mean
Mason Carlisle laughs do you plan online
with your subscribers anytime or just
your friends neither honestly when I'm
reviewing games I just have to jump
between them so fast that I often don't
really get the time for the social side
of gaming as much as I would love to but
I am planning on like sorting one day a
month where I can play with subscribers
I just don't know how to go about it
like what game do I pick what platform
do I pick how do I pick a small group of
people from a large group of people who
would like to I just don't I don't know
how to do it so genuinely if anyone has
any suggestions yeah I would really
appreciate them please leave them below
because I would love to do this but
don't know where to get started
the halo lover what is your favorite
band / hottest my favorite band is under
oath my favorite artist is childish
gambino Mendes
x-23 das what is something you've wanted
to do but haven't had the courage / time
to do if I had the time and I guess the
courage I would get like she-hulk levels
of bluff so stuff has happened in my
life that's made me really value the
importance of my own personal strengths
so I've been weight lifting for like I
don't know maybe two years and while I
would consider myself stronger than most
people I'm not nearly as strong as I
could be but that's because the time and
the dedication required Alex Mason how
far do you want to go in your career are
you already at your limit or do you feel
you could exceed and do more and enjoy
it at the same time
I have this like problem where I never
feel like I've achieved enough so I
don't think that I will ever feel like
I've done enough I think that's a like a
thing that really drives me to keep
doing more is that I feel crappy about
myself if I don't achieve a lot in a
small amount of time Sharlee suck ass
what's your ultimate goal in life this
is such a rough question to ask someone
who's just turned 21 I have no ideas
anyone have any idea I feel Tory Patrice
Eston zas what is my stressful and
demanding aspects of your Korea and how
many manage to overcome them the
stressful parts of reviewing games is
the deadlines
how about calm them I haven't really I
guess the honest answer to that is that
I have sacrificed my social life rebecca
fernandez a super important question do
you keep a Vegemite in the cupboard or
the fridge I keep my bedroom I in the
cupboard if you keep your Vegemite in
the fridge it gets really hot like
painfully hot and you just try to stab
it and it's just what what are you doing
just in covered man come on Jessie
Lefevre us what is your preferred
bicycle mountain street or hybrid what
is your favorite area to ride if you
even do this is a stupid random question
but I want to answer it anyway
I'm pretty sure I ride on a street bike
and I go for rides with my mom all the
time and we go near lakes and stuff but
clarin February 24 hours do you play
horror games if you do what game is it
um look I play games sometimes but I'm
really not good at it I'm fine with
movies I can laugh at horror movies
books whatever TV shows fine games that
are scary make me want to cry like a
little girl
like the little girl that I truly am I
did consider doing Silent Hill PT as a
let's play because I know it would be
entertaining because of how freaked out
I get but decided against it because I
wouldn't be able to sleep and I that's
it sleep is important to me fat burrito
1600s I think you about doing videos
like you were just getting both with
both videogame and anime but I don't
know where to start to go about it any
advice to your success
mostly I would not consider myself
successful on YouTube I'm not a good
person to look up to I have uploaded
like 60 videos in two years which is
terrible but I do have advice and that
would be for anyone who asks me this
question just have fun Wade Simpson oz
Charizard XO Charizard why Charles I'd
why I got Pokemon X
and had to like do the thing to make
sure that I would get Charizard y
because Charizard X just doesn't even
look like Charizard it's like chars out
but dead Aleksandra fridge asks I would
love to know what's your most favorite
game from your childhood is or favorites
Age of Empires perfect dark banjo tooie
pokemon yellow and that's it for me
today everyone who because enjoyed this
Q&A I'll do another one for 40k if that
ever happens if you have questions for
Q&A as I announce what I'm going to be
doing them on other social media but if
you want to leave a question below then
maybe I'll pick some up the next time as
well so I am Alana thank you for
watching and I will see you guys next
time